levez les mesures anticovides inflation
galopante élection au Québec et tension
internationale l'année 2022 a été bien
remplie l'heure est maintenant au bilan
[Musique]
nous avons une nouveau chef
quel est l'événement marquant des 6
derniers mois et quelle est l'erreur
politique comme plusieurs d'entre vous
j'ai été déçu quelle politicien a
briller on a utilisé les mesures qui
étaient proportionnelles et nécessaire
lequel a échoué
que devrions-nous surveiller l'an
prochain le plus grand problème qu'on
nous c'est un manque de
personnel et que réservera le Père Noël
à nos politiciens quelles devraient être
leur résolution pour le Nouvel An ici
Daniel Thibault dimanche 11 décembre
bienvenue à cette édition spéciale des
coulisses du pouvoir notre bilan 2022
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bon dimanche c'est
devenu au fil des ans l'une de nos
émissions préférées à préparer avant de
quitter pour le congé des Fêtes quoi de
mieux que de prendre une petite heure
pour revenir sur les événements qui ont
marqué le paysage politique des 6
derniers mois et anticiper un peu ce qui
risque de retenir notre attention dans
la nouvelle année et surtout qui de
mieux pour mener cet exercice que nous
fidèles collaborateurs qui sont là
chaque semaine on les a pour une heure
cette semaine avec castorguer est
animateur de miser info et si première
chantant libère et chroniqueurs au
Toronto de l'actualité Michel COG qui
nous rejoint virtuellement pour des
raisons qui sont devenues évidentes au
fil après deux ans de pandémie et
chroniqueurs à la presse et à
Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour Merci d'être merci d'être là
aujourd'hui on va évidemment repasser
une série d'événements qu'on a vu au
cours des derniers mois j'étais un œil
sur l'avenir mais avant de faire ça on
va acheter un œil sur ce que notre
équipe a retenu comme élément
significatif
c'est encore un de l'automne et on vous
revient tout de suite après
aujourd'hui nous pouvons annoncer des
ajustements à nos mesures sanitaires ce
sont les mots qui attendaient depuis
deux ans des Canadiens assoiffés de
liberté
[Musique]
mais le système sclérosé est incapable
de répondre à la demande ben voilà les
gens attendent dehors ils campent il y a
pas de toilette il y a pas d'eau je suis
vraiment désolée de voir que les
Canadiens ont dû passer pour cette
expérience une valise bleue on appelle
Arcada on a aucune réponse c'est l'enfer
l'économie reprend de la vigueur et
alimente l'inflation en juin et latin
8,4% du jamais vu en 40 ans les taux
d'intérêt augmentent les prix des
aliments et de l'essence aussi tu sais
pas répondre
non très économie va ralentir car la
banque centrale doit s'attaquer à
l'inflation en Ontario dogford est relu
en Colombie-Britannique John organe tire
sa révérence
en Alberta Daniel Smet succède à Jason
Kenny et promet de tenir tête à juste un
Trudeau
au Québec François Legault mis sur la
question identitaire et le déclin du
français pour obtenir son second mandat
la nation québécoise pourrait être forte
il faut protéger le français sinon il y
a des inquiétudes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la taxe orange place Québec solidaire
sur la défensive moi j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu comme de la magistrat
un peu comme si vous étiez au pays des
merveilles monsieur nado Dubois
merci les libéraux et le Parti québécois
peinent à s'imposer votre planification
mène au déclin le plus marqué de
l'histoire du Québec en français
continuons
au final la victoire de laque est
écrasante 90 des 125 sièges du salon
bleu et laisse dans son sillage une
opposition décimée la pire performance
de l'histoire du Parti libéral j'ai
informé le président du parti ce matin
de ma démission à titre de chef du Parti
libéral du Québec et des conservateurs
aux espoirs anéantis au moment où je
vous on a très exactement le même nombre
de votes que le Parti libéral du Québec
mais il manque 20 députés
le décès de la reine Élisabeth après 70
ans de règne ramène sur la sellette la
pertinence du serment au souverain le
Parti québécois en fait une question de
principe j'ai eu un
arbre
parce que vous avez pas prêté serment
donc exactement
les conservateurs se choisissent un
troisième chef en 7 ans le travail
commence ce soir pour remplacer ce vieux
gouvernement qui me coûte plus cher et
que vous apporte moins
en l'Atlantique le passage dévastateur
de l'ouragan Fiona rappelle l'urgence de
s'adapter à une nouvelle réalité
climatique dans certains cas ça voudra
peut-être dire que on devra déplacer des
gens qui sont dans des zones à risque
en Ukraine les troupes russes sans
lisent
et les multiples allégations d'un
gérance de la Chine au Canada soulève de
vives inquiétudes le premier se devrait
expliquer pourquoi il a échoué à
protéger nos intérêts et notre sécurité
souvenir d'un hiver mouvementé la
commission rouleau ramène sur la
sellette le convoi de la liberté j'ai
toujours trouvé que le peuple était pas
assez entendu par nos élus à ce
moment-là ça commençait à être pas mal
clair que la situation était si urgente
avait un une préoccupation que ça
pourrait se sentirer dégringoler et
après les vaccins les vacances le retour
à une vie plus normale le problème des
urgences est à grandeur du Québec
et à l'aube d'un premier Noël déconfiné
la situation dans les hôpitaux offrent
du rappel la crise n'est peut-être pas
complètement terminée
le paysage politique s'est transformé au
cours des six derniers mois avec les
élections Québec les mi-mandats aux
États-Unis et l'arrivée enceinte de
nouveaux chefs de parties de nouveaux
dossiers chauds aussi ça a probablement
inspiré nos passionnés pour ce premier
tour d'échange je commence avec vous
Chantal l'événement marquant des six
derniers mois alors j'ai pris le mot
marquant pour l'événement l'événement
changeant c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
campagnes électorales mais il y a pas eu
de changement et donc le plus grand
changement dans le paysage c'est quand
même l'arrivée triomphale pour ne pas
dire triomphalistes à la tête du parti
conservatoire ou le mot est pas trop
fort effectivement les deux allaient
ensemble dans ce cas-ci pourquoi un
événement marquant ben d'abord quand le
chef de l'opposition officielle est
remplacé c'est toujours le début d'une
série d'ajustements de la part de tous
les autres partis et des premiers
ministres provinciaux mais surtout parce
que ce chef conservateur il arrive à un
moment dans le cycle c'est cool
normalement l'usure commence à avoir
raison de la capacité du gouvernement
sortant de se faire élire trois mandats
c'est beaucoup en politique canadienne
10 ans c'est à peu près le bail normal
donc pierre poillière c'est un
adversaire que Justin Trudeau a besoin
de prendre triplement au sérieux par
rapport à ceux qui l'ont précédés
effectivement vous êtes d'accord avec
Chantal moi j'ai choisi l'arrivée de
Pierre pour le lièvre aussi puis pour
acheter ce que Chantal dit je regarde
attentivement sa stratégie depuis qu'il
est en place depuis le 10 septembre
notamment ça relation avec les médiums
vous savez chacun des chefs qui a
justement chacun des chefs conservateurs
depuis Steven Harper qui s'installe se
dit on va se passer des médias
traditionnels puis on va aller parler
directement aux électeurs via soit les
réseaux sociaux soit des milieux
régionaux à l'époque de Steven Harper et
vient toujours un moment où on doit
reconsidérer cette stratégie là parce
que la masse n'est pas nécessairement
sur Twitter regarde encore beaucoup
l'immédiat traditionnels ou les écoute
et là de comme piapoli va bouder les
médias presque tout et juste dans les
dernières semaines on recommence à se
poser des questions parce qu'on savait
pas ce que c'était une bonne stratégie
est-ce qu'il parle vraiment monsieur
madame tout le monde c'est le fan
d'avoir trois 4000 likes sur Twitter
mais il y a pas beaucoup de gens sur
Twitter qui vont changer d'opinion et
donc j'ai hâte de voir comment on va
recalibrer si on recalibre cette
stratégie là parce que la plupart des
chefs ont eu à recalibrer cette
stratégie de l'autre partie
conservatoire tout dans l'opposition
monsieur un peu pouvait se permettre
quand il était premier ministre tout le
monde s'occupe de toi quand tes chefs
d'opposition il faut que tu attires
l'attention un peu puis pour l'instant
ça a été un automne qui n'a pas été
flamboyant autant que sa victoire pour
bien polir même s'il est en avance dans
les sondages il y a rien de qui pour lui
encore voilà Michel vous vous êtes allé
de l'autre côté de la frontière oui à
cause des implications de ce côté-ci
c'est-à-dire que l'événement marquant
quant à moi a été la quasi victoire des
démocrates ou le véritable défaite des
républicains déjà comme vous voudrez
mais au Canada une majorité des
républicains dans les deux chambres du
Congrès on aurait eu des problèmes avec
ça s'arrêter une balade de législation
qui aurait touché le Canada qui aurait
pu arriver là avec un pouvoir divisé au
Congrès ça donne un gros répit au
gouvernement canadien et au gouvernement
provinciaux de ne pas voir toutes sortes
de folies avec on a vu ce que ça a donné
à l'arrivée de Monsieur Trump entre
autres et l'impact que ça peut avoir de
ce côté-ci de la frontière effectivement
la leçon politique de cette dernière
moitié d'année avec quelle d'après vous
que lorsque les fondamentaux sont
solides c'est à dire que ce n'est pas
une élection de changement peu importe
ce qui se passe les électeurs n'ont pas
envie de changement on peut donc perdre
une campagne électorale comme François
Legault l'a perdu
ou gagné une campagne électorale comme
Pierre Paul saint-pierre-plamondon
Gabriel Nadaud du mois boit l'ont fait
et ça ne change à peu près rien au
paysage politique c'est à dire que quand
les gens ont décidé que le gouvernement
méritait d'être élu soit parce que la
gestion de la pandémie leur entamé une
partie du mandat soit parce qu'on
jugeait qu'avec les avaient bien fait
parce que l'équipe nous plaisait
davantage que celle des autres même si
on a deux débats des chefs benordinaire
qu'on s'enfer sur l'immigration sur
certains dossiers les gens se disent mon
choix était fait alors ça prouve tout à
l'heure Chantal parlait de 3 cycles
électoraux Ottawa on est rendu au bout
de 10 ans quand c'est une élection de
changement c'est extrêmement difficile
d'y résister l'inverse est aussi vrai
lorsque les gens ont décidé qu'il ne
changeaient pas grand chose qu'on peut
échanger même si les parties de position
font tout en leur possible pour y
arriver Michel vous avez retenu aussi un
élément dont on a beaucoup parlé durant
l'élection québécoise et après surtout
le mode de scrutin est démocratiquement
incorrect effects il ne reflète plus la
situation politique réelle ça donne des
gouvernements très forts ça donne pas
nécessairement des gouvernements plus
efficaces par exemple alors cette
conversation là sur le mode de scrutin
même si le gouvernement va essayer de
l'étouffer le plus possible elle est
rendue dans la population puis ça va
continuer vers
conversation là tout le monde essaie de
l'avoir puis c'est compliqué j'entends
presque toujours on dit que elle va
rester un petit bout de temps mais
généralement ça s'est fait là-dessus
mais je pense que la première phase de
Michel on va les retrouver dans des
publicités les participants de la
réforme électorale
moi aussi j'ai trouvé ma leçon dans les
élections politiques au Québec mais en
reculant un peu plus pas pour dire
l'électeurs francophones franchement pas
dans le moment d'appétit pour un retour
à la polarisation souvenir fédéraliste
et
sans égard à une campagne ternes
François Legault a vraiment trouvé dans
la zone grise nationaliste la zone de
confort
d'une pluralité des lecteurs et ça va
être très très difficile de casser ça
parce que on ne savait avant que c'était
la zone de confort mais il y avait pas
de véhicule
maintenant il y en a un est-ce que
la succession de monsieur Legault il y a
un jour il y en aura une je sais qu'il y
a pas ça quand on dit ça mais il est pas
éternel est-ce qu'on va réussir à se
tenir dans cette zone grise là de façon
efficace ça ça va être un gros point
d'interrogation mais pour l'instant ça
dit quand même quelque chose c'est pas
parce que Monsieur degault ici bon aussi
excitant que ça qui a gagné un deuxième
mandat c'est parce qu'il est situé sur
l'échiquier là où beaucoup de Québécois
se retrouvent et quand il y a beaucoup
de gens dans ce coin là d'habitude c'est
payant pour un parti électorale
effectivement l'erreur politique c'est
fou comment la campagne québécoise
générée beaucoup beaucoup de vos
réponses Michel l'erreur politique c'est
un peu évident vous verrez
politique Michel
la taxe orange
stoppé tout net leur montée en plein
milieu de la campagne et ça crée des
problèmes qui sont toujours pas résolus
avec la classe moyenne de gens qui
disent là ces gens-là pensent qu'un
propriétaire de duplexe arrose monstre
un millionnaire qui doit être taxé comme
tel ça ça ne
ça vraiment nuit ou partie est tel qu'il
ne réussiront pas à rembobiner ce fil là
et ils l'ont pas toujours pas fait ils
vont avoir des problèmes j'entends je
vais choisir la même chose pour
exactement les mêmes raisons à partir de
ce moment-là et l'élan de Québec
solidaire il y en avait au début c'est
retourné contre Québec solidaire et on a
un peu l'impression qu'ils sont dû à un
million ça va frapper l'imaginaire je
sais pas si long que ça de faire le
total et de se rendre compte que en 2022
un million ça a pas exactement le même
effet sur les esprits que en 1990
votre votre erreur politique j'en ai
deux je ça donne tous les deux à dominer
Anglade d'abord pour avoir fait campagne
aux îles la Madeleine et down Gava lors
des derniers jours de la campagne
électorale de la campagne métro qui
avait aucune chance de remporter ces
deux sacréscriptions là avoir effet
peut-être des tours dans Verdun dans
Laval où on a perdu des circonscriptions
par quelques voix seulement aurait été
plus payant pour dominer candle je sais
pas qui lui a conseillé ça mais on
n'avait pas soit les bons chiffres soit
la bonne stratégie mais ça c'est une
erreur de campagne qui peut avoir coûté
quelques sièges au libéraux et la
gestion de Marie-Claude Nikos a député
de Vaudreuil qui pour toutes sortes de
bonnes et mauvaises raisons voulaient un
poste peut-être qu'elle ne le méritait
pas je ne le sais pas mais expulser une
députée pour des raisons comme celle-là
ok tout un chaos et après si tu le
départ de Dominique Anglade donc ça a
pas été pour elle dans ces deux colocs
très payants donc je reste avec vous
avec l'événement cette fois aux
conséquences qu'on a sous-estimé vous
savez le vol d'un dépliant peut mener à
beaucoup de choses notamment l'élection
d'un chef de parti politique à
l'Assemblée nationale donc l'événement
je pense que c'est que la candidate de
Québec solidaire dans Camille lorrain à
Montréal ça fait prendre la main dans la
boîte aux lettres en retirant la
dépliant du PQ et on a été obligé de la
sacrifier à Québec solidaire on a ouvert
la voie royale à Paul
saint-pierre-la-mondon pour se rendre à
l'Assemblée nationale parce que les
chiffres qu'on a revu le soir des
élections montre qu'il n'aurait
probablement pas gagné qui a mis Laurent
une candidate de Québec solidaire avait
été encore en poste ça fait en sorte
donc qu'on est passé de 2 à 3 députés au
PQ mais surtout qu'on a la tête
d'affiche du PQ le chef en place qui a
permis ensuite d'attirer l'attention
autant sur le serment au roi entre
autres automne on pourrait revenir
sûrement mais donc un petit détail un
grain de sable dans une campagne
électorale du côté de Québec solidaire a
peut-être permis aux parties québécois
d'abord de garder leur chef est
difficile mais ensuite d'avoir une plus
grande résonance qui ne le pensait même
donc petit détail mais qui a des grandes
répercussions
à la succession de Paul
saint-pierre-flamondon
ont été écrasés
et là je dis pas que c'était son
ambition il y a des gens qui voyaient et
François Blanchet passer du bloc au PQ
il y a des gens qui se voyaient
s'installer comme calife à la place du
calife à Ottawa c'est tout d'un château
de cartes et là je suis pas en train de
dire que il François blanchesse voyait à
Québec mais les gens qui le pensaient
en train de parler de lui là ou soit de
son refus de faire ce passage là soit du
fait que son passage va ouvrir la voie à
quelqu'un d'autre tout ça tout ça pour
un moment ou un dépliant ça dure une
fraction voilà un petit moment et pouf
c'est un battement d'aile de papillon
Michel votre événement conséquence
estimé
oubliez pas qu'il y avait une caméra de
surveillance maintenant
[Musique]
13% et 0 député du Parti conservateur du
Québec c'est un électorat fragile
électorat qui est pas toujours dans le
débat démocratique et la façon dont on
va au dont on va jouer ça et je ne dis
pas qu'il faut donner à Monsieur Duhem
tous les privilèges qui demandent loin
de là il y a pas de député il y a pas de
député là c'est quand même que le prix
d'entrée au Parlement ça mais quand même
il y a des gens qui vont sentir que le
système marche pas pour eux et il faut
faire très attention à ça c'est un homme
conséquent des millions de personnes
c'est quelque chose dont on pourrait
facilement sous-estimer les conséquences
ça revient encore notre la question de
la représentation puis de la réforme
démocratique du mode de ce que tu es un
Chantal votre événement
dans le départ forcé Jason Kenny comme
un premier ministre d'Alberta parce que
quelque part et savoir un peu dans le
sens de ce que Michel vient de dire sur
le demi-million des lecteurs qui se
retrouvent pas dans les autres parties
là ce sont les électeurs qui se
reconnaissent pas même dans ce qui est
le Parti conservateur encore pur de
prostituer cette année c'était
l'incarnation quand même on va pas dire
que c'est un libéral
ce serait vraiment exagéré il y avait de
l'expérience et il a été poussé dehors
entre autres par le mouvement
anti-mesure sanitaires on se fera pas de
secret et par des gens qui à l'instar de
certains des manifestants
Ottawa pense qu'on peut démolir le
système actuel installé un projet de loi
pour déclarer que la liberté est
souveraine et ne respecte pas les lois
fédérales et ça a donné le premier
ministre d'une province majeure au
Canada l'Alberta et là-dedans il y a
comme un message si vous canalisez pas
ces énergies-là de façon plus
constructive ça risque de détruire par
exemple dans ce que si le mouvement
conservateur canadien surveiller des
élections qui s'enviennent ce printemps
en Alberta ça va être intéressant
d'avoir le résultat ça met la table
entre conversation dans quelques minutes
on jette un regard sur les performances
bonnes moins bonnes parfois de nos élus
des nôtres